you hear about that big study claiming
big
tech really doesn't favor liberals it
was funded
by a big tech liberal bet you won't find
out that fact in any of the mainstream
reports
but the guy behind it is billionaire
craig newmark he also donated millions
to fight fake news and a ton to biden's
campaign as well
he also founded craigslist the online
bulletin board where i sell my discarded
swimwear
but last night tucker revealed the study
was in fact no study at all
we get some numbers on that nyu well no
actually we can
in the words of the quote study pinning
down precise proportions on censorship
is impossible because twitter doesn't
release sufficient data are you
following the reasoning here
their conclusion twitter is not biased
and we can be certain it's not biased
because twitter refuses to release data
on who it bans
in other words a fake study for a guy
who claims he doesn't like fake news
it was designed for the media so they
wouldn't have to do their jobs and
investigate the actual claims
but the quote research is about as
researchy as turning on the lights to
your living room
to assess the existence of whales yep
no whales there really having a big tech
lib fun to study on whether big tech is
biased that's like me funding a
study on how great i am or a study
saying
jessie has the best hair in cable news
and it's funded by the jesse waters
institute for follicular studies
or how about one concluding that jasper
is indeed america's dog
and that's funded by the dana perino
university of dog selfies
and did you know that juan williams is
right on everything
that research was funded by juan
williams
so before you see a study that says
there's no massive crime wave
i'd check first to see if it was funded
by criminals or worse cnn
fact is the great thing about being a
rich lib you can build a case for
anything and the media will back you up
100
it's how they lie to you and keep you in
the dark but of course that's all bs
according to a new study by the people
who lie to you and keep you in the dark
you know dagon i didn't know you were on
the show today so i didn't come up with
a
study for you so if you were
commissioning a study
on yourself what would the ideal
conclusion be
uh that i speak the proper way and
dropping your g's
is the way that everybody should
pronounce words
that i'm speaking kings and the queen's
english over here
i don't know what y'all are speaking
are you surprised by this finding not at
all because you're actually describing
what i'll call the left wingnut
armada you've got the tech industry and
with the
tech monopolies they're all powerful and
unchecked
along with the media along with
the with academia and then the
government
and they feel they don't have opinions
mind you
they're right they're correct they're
just and they're moral
there is only one legitimate point of
view and
it is theirs and if you don't fall in
line with them if you don't agree with
them
you're wrong and now they're so
emboldened and aligned with one another
they will also
destroy you you see that with with
technology just with the
shutting down of parlor but
we've been here before and ultimately
people
turn against the outrage the pushback on
censorship and cancellation
you saw with the red scare the house on
american activities committee and
mccarthyism
but the scary thing is even if
righteousness wins out
there's a lot of carnage before that
happens with lives and livelihoods
destroyed
worst case scenario is that the dems
this kind of
collective joining in
it they went out and democrats are in
power and anybody who has a differing
opinion or a different voice
you're destroyed and so is our republic
[Music]
you know juan you know studies like this
or when when the media covers studies
like this
isn't it their responsibility to say who
paid for it
i used to when i worked in health
journalism there was always a little
note at the end of the study
this study on orange juice reducing
cholesterol
was funded by the orange juice board it
was always kind of they had to do it
i don't think it was hidden greg but i
must say i'm struck by what you said in
this
in the terms that you know usually you
and i disagree and i think
this may be an occasion where we meet at
the mountaintop
but just that we come up different sides
of the mountain
because from my side of the mountain i
think that
big tech with its ability to tell us how
to think
you know what to buy how to vote i think
that that
is too big and they need to be regulated
in some cases
maybe even broken up but they certainly
need some kind of
uh you know interface with the public so
the public understands
what's going on and why they do what
they do and when they do it
they're too powerful but from my side of
the mountain i just wanted to say i
don't
i don't want conservative thought
limited i don't think it
is limited i when i look at these
platforms i see
ben shapiro uh you know i see dan
bongino they got
the leading sites out there many of them
are conservative sites that are the top
sites on social media
so i don't see that there's any bias
against the conservatives but
i think that when you start talking
about things like killing politicians
when you start plotting violent
seditious acts
against the capital of the united states
when you embrace conspiracy theories
when that kind of trash
is spread on these sites i then think
people have a legitimate right to say
this is damaging to us as a country to
our society to our ability
to have honest discourse and i think
that's what's going on i think that's
why you see today in the congress
you have republicans like mitch
mcconnell the senate majority league
saying
that kind of thinking is cancerous and
dangerous to not only to the
republican party but to us as an
american people
and that's what's going on here i don't
care who paid for the study
i just think that we need to come
together and say you know this kind of
internet sensation that's distorting our
public discourse
is damaging but you know
jesse you know the answer to this is it
depends on who you are
because this isn't applied to uh
celebrities on twitter who say burn it
all down
or people making threats to trump or to
uh to trump supporters
uh or any kind of ominous warnings
to anybody that is not a leftist that
stuff seems to just fly right by
you can you can tweet support of
farrakhan that's okay
yeah greg permission to make a sports
analogy
permission granted okay so
you're watching a football game and on
every single play
the refs flag a penalty on your team
they never throw flags at the other team
and you get blown out
and at the end of the game the
announcers come on the air and they say
wasn't that a very well called game
and then you find out the announcers are
on the payroll of the other team
that's how rigged this is i can't name
one liberal
who's been flagged or censored on social
media i mean juan named
bongino and shapiro they've been flagged
and censored
i mean you're telling me the party of
the left doesn't lie or push
fake news the covingtons the collusions
the smellets
the fine people hoaxes the mailbox
hoaxes
the hands up don't shooters the people
who said that
the arctic ice caps were going to melt
20 years ago
these people you're going to give one
political party
a monopoly on the truth well in that
case 150 years ago
the democratic party's truth commission
would have said
slavery's great and they would have
called the abolitionists
people pushing disinformation see what i
did there
what this is really about is the legacy
media
losing their share in the marketplace
everybody knows they lie
and people on the right social media fox
news and podcasts
they're starting to gain traction so
instead of competing with them they're
conspiring with the state the democratic
party
and silicon valley to slap a danger
label
on conservative influencers and propping
up czars and commissions to shut them
down
because they can't compete with them
i think i learned that it's good we
didn't have the internet back during the
civil war dana
final thoughts to you okay first of all
i never had a ken doll
i don't even think i ever had a barbie
because my parents wouldn't buy me one
and they didn't believe in like the
whole barbie scene
so i didn't get mono from kissing is
that all you've been thinking about in
this block
so you've been thinking about that intro
in the entire block
well i mean it did take me by surprise
but i loved it okay this is what i
wanted to say
um in addition to the censorship issue
there's this whole thing of um being
compliant with terms of service now we
could all say sure we should all
if the terms of service if you would
agree to it you should you should be
responsible for it but
that isn't applied evenly from liberals
to conservatives
i'll give you an example think of jimmy
kimmel their
show put up a fake video of
vice president mike pence sent putting
empty boxes of ppe
out now that's clearly against terms of
service you can't manipulate videos
and it took a massive amount of outrage
to get twitter to flag it take it down
contrast that with just take your pick
there was one time when
donald trump jr put up a video of biden
that was got out of context it made him
look like he
was stumbling over his words but
actually it wasn't that it wasn't
manipulated but it didn't have full
context
it was immediately flagged so if things
were applied evenly i think people would
have a little bit more confidence
i think you're absolutely right and
congratulations on day three of the
turtlenecks
all right